so to introduce the body today we're
trying a free man ting with a very
special guest a longtime friend mr.
Jacob banks um there'll be links aplenty
below when editing pops off yeah but
yeah man the topic I was thinking about
for yourself
was boolean okay because I find it like
a whirlwind topic from a million
different avenues and I thought like
have you ever been a victim or
contributed to bullying of any shape or
form the man in me wants but not much
never I don't know I think so I think
people have definitely tried to bully
you yeah I think there's been attempts
but I'm cracked so it's never really
pans that well I've definitely been a
bully just one specific time in my life
I remember vividly haunts me even I'd
say I bullied one dude and I hated it I
was so sorry still AM
those race if you listen Rhys pologize
my weapon I just got caught up in stuff
man I was just being dumb m'as there was
back in scourges where we had peeing
which brings out the worst in everyone
frankly conversation yes sir he was
getting just everyone was just like
throwing balls at him just being
annoying just been annoying little kids
and then I got a bit carrot you know
remember when in school gyms you had
that little Rudd to open up the window
if it was home oh yeah I drew for that I
drew for one of those Paul came in with
it and he started to cry and I seemed as
a sort of cry I made everyone stop a
psychologist probably continue this this
is terrible about yeah and then then he
kind of saw that moment as a chance to
like prove himself that he'd swung for
me
and then didn't had to slump him but um
it was terrible time and I felt so bad
for I apologize for weeks
um yeah I think sometimes it's people
people bully because it's easier to be
part of something that segregation
drives human beings weird it's like you
want to believe you want to belong to
one side of the table so it's either the
bullies or people who are being bullied
so if everyone's bullying it's easier to
just be like I'm gonna be one of those
people or not and I think at that moment
I chose to be one of those people I
probably the only time in my life I I've
ever done that is terrible all about
youth um I know you've done
you know I've bullied I can't think of a
specific time where I feel like I've
bullied someone I don't laugh alone
if someone bullied around you the way
you laugh would make me cry like even if
we did nothing yeah yeah you're the way
you laugh at stuff is terrible
I know place I just I see humor in
everything obviously sometimes it's
negative sometimes positive sometimes
just a thing I just humor in everything
like the same way comedians make jokes
about rape and [ __ ] I just see humor
yeah obviously the topic like we said
discussed for the topic of rape itself
isn't it's a nice it's not nice to talk
about but the joke and the context is in
is different yeah so I've done this out
of I don't necessarily feel like I put
it anyone if I have or if I don't throw
like a but people assume I have then
obviously then that's two different
arguments but I don't think I've ever
put myself in a situation that's my
that's my view anyway I don't feel like
I have I don't feel like I've ever been
bullied nothing stands out I want to say
yes though because I feel like there
have been times in my life where
naturally just just general selection
you get picked on I mean general
selection and especially growing up
phase more like around there yeah yeah
nine stage where you're trying I can say
you're trying to find your crowd yeah
have your the bullies or your the bully
our life
and I feel like because I wasn't I
wasn't a very much confident well-spoken
that kind of person has always
challenged people that I am now because
of my career I felt like I got put in
that group of by he's easy so you just
might as well attempts to bully do you
know I mean because it's the way but the
way people portray people might just
assume you're an easy target and that
from if one person assumes everyone
everyone I see yeah so I feel like I was
associated with that by default yeah
that make sense
all by yourself I've been on both sides
of him and so I've done bullying twice
in my life one time was when I moved out
of Luton to North and I was brand new
and there was a there was like a
unpopular child in the class this is
like year 78 guy called Lee and everyone
was picking him and was an art class I
remember and everyone was like everyone
will roll up to him I'd be like Lee do
you think you could beat me up I never
like now no no no no never lead you
think you could beat me up no no no no
no and then come to me
mmm you know like James asking am i I
won't [ __ ] ask him ask him ask him ask
him I said I don't want to ask him like
I don't want to be part of this and then
I [ __ ] asked him and then I was like
alright my lead you think you could beat
me up I said yes and then we had a fire
after school mmm that's how bad it got
the peer pressure was so deep we had to
scrap off the school and it was the
worst one of the worst things I've ever
experienced because not only did I
crumble to like the peer pressure of it
I put someone in physical danger because
I was too much of a [ __ ] and didn't
want to be disliked in like my first
week of a new school
so yeah we scrapped I'm not like banged
me he banged me but then what made it
worse is that as soon as I rocked him he
dropped and like six of my boys just ran
in his type kickin image [ __ ] and I was
like nah man this is not the one or the
need the need to be accepted as crazy
like we think about so much of life is
that so much of life fundamentally is
about I want to feel seen and it drives
like drives race gender like equality if
everybody needs to build everyone is to
belong to a group and we almost don't
care what the ramifications are of that
group it's just I just need to be on one
side the idea of standing alone is so
daunting to people that it we make such
terrible decisions off the back of it
it's like and we choose based on what's
available to our self for example is
human connection is we will keep finding
yourself to separate ourselves every
time so for example is like you know if
I am black Nigerian and many other
things but I choose which adjective I
use depending on who's in a room yeah so
if I'm around a bunch of white people I
am black so if I'm around a bunch of
black people I'm African if I'm a bunch
of African people I am lying German if
I'm a lot of my German people I am
Yoruba and then I go for my religion
yeah I might go for my height so it's
like a filter said yes I will do
anything to be like Oh like well yeah
I'm here you're there and it's just like
we don't care what comes with that group
it's just like we need to separate it's
so drastic like we're always looking for
something to separate us from them yeah
and it's weird I cuz at the very minimum
we're just all human at the very base
level in our nation but we always try to
like notice you do that I do this and
it's just weird man
mm-hmm you have a other time where I was
this is like this one is nice nice was
horrible but it's the time when I was
bullied this is a completely deaf
different sub-sector in terms of like
not fitting in so I used to have
obviously my Cooper friends
I lived on one side of town most of my
friends in the other side of town are
one boy called Rob who'd walk home with
me because he lived near where I live
and like he was like he was someone who
got not picked on like he was in like
the popular crowd but in terms what
you're saying he was the only African
all of us were black comics raised but
he was the only African so again
something to just her little ticks that
and I think he had a hard time at home
as well so we used to walk home out of
nowhere everyone was blessed I don't
know where one time he just like tricked
me up and all right leave it did do
nothing and then a few weeks later man
started like pushing me punching me a
little bit playful and I was supposed
this guy and then he used to you know
those switch sticks those bendy green
sticks or they get off the tree and one
day picked one off the tree in style
whipping the [ __ ] army and one was like
do some back do something back do
something I was up you're my boy like
why are you doing this but he would
never do it at school in front of the
above man we're gonna only do it on our
way home and I never wanted the
confrontation to escalate to a pool
we're having a scrap because for one I'm
just not really a confrontational guy
even in extreme situations sometimes and
for two it was just me and him like
fighting someone all-out when his
literary to people there some I would
die from when does it end so yeah he
just continued continued continued into
one time my brother was with my little
brother and he was still in primary
school and he started it my brother was
crying his eyes out cries I have Kaiser
I leave my profile my doing his set
reset reset reset row so that's when
obviously I had sir at the back here I'm
done with this I'm done with this um and
then you got smack you just have to
leave it sometimes you need that though
like I feel like that's natural
selection so I like peace and love and
all that sometimes you know I smart
people know sometimes it's the only
thing that registers for some people and
I like like I've had friends growing up
where we've just had to rumble yeah like
it's just like I stood as much as I
believe in I believe in like a human
beings growing morally but I still
believe this sort of natural selection
like I still believe it are very cool
with store animals they store alpha and
betas sometimes we need to see who who's
who who but do you not feel like with a
robe situation do you not feel like he
was he took his advantage of picking on
you because you walked home together
[ __ ] because he got bullied by your
group ever end up that's right
that was his relief lease right yeah
yeah he was so vexed about the situation
and I was just frail ambassador Lord the
gang yeah and because I was this again
was so I was so new yeah he just fought
Brad this is an easy opportunity yeah
everyone needs to feel like an alpha
somewhere somewhere yeah yeah bunch of
man deducted it to the to their missus
day you're at work getting moved to you
by Tim Tims custody writing you get home
your hype into your missus you waste man
what Tim was cussing you out you didn't
say nothing
he's laughing and in you're at home
acting up like people I take out their
frustration on people who didn't hurt
them and it's weird and it's just bro
there's so much more our generation
where we need therapy cuz like so much
to unpack at all times a bunch of people
it's just everyone needs to feel like
the king somewhere and that often means
that someone has to be on the receiving
end of that and it's just peak but it's
just life
you said to smart come up well that's
what nd did
that's what that's what shut it down he
just got one smack and I was dreading
the comeback bar just like I can't have
my lil brother crying I can't I can't
bang cuz it would change not only will
it'll change so much for him at that age
it was like it's not only gonna change
how he sees his older brother yeah it's
gonna change what he sees friendships as
yeah he's gonna change as what he sees
violence as what's okay what's not okay
not just right now that I can't bang
camel bang yeah man I just thought that
was a kind of interesting topic to pick
up just because ya like humans being
human to human [ __ ] and sometimes as the
warden or as it is and also I've thought
I'd bring up because I had a feeling
that either one of you would admit to
say and I've been the bully and probably
in that time you didn't realize you
would be in it and I boy up because I've
watched a powerful video I don't even
see there's a powerful video every week
one high school might be middle school
sign America one gay kid was getting
bullied
one guy called him a [ __ ] was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then the gay guy
obviously the bully was on his one that
was in the whole class that no one was
back in bully no one it's all silence my
said call me [ __ ] again and he's like
brought you a [ __ ] he peel back and
smack the [ __ ] out of this kid and the
guy just have to stand and shake Spanish
shake when bullies get circle is the
funniest thing well because that like
there's so much of being a bully or so
much of being who you are is hell-bent
on the fact that you don't believe
nothing what happened I love seeing it I
love I live for that I live for it
because because now you have to find
this happened now now and I burn when
when when people who've been bullied get
strength but they get the strength of a
thousand slaves yes it's different it's
like Descartes leaves like
i I make the I said it's all the time
it's like as a black person if you
racially abused me and I fight you I
can't lose yeah
it's never happened no one's ever
racially abused and lost a fire kiss the
strength of my forefathers is here is he
icarly's this fight the same way if you
bully someone and they fight back
they're winning mmm they win it they
have to they like if you're round you're
you're rattled anyway because you didn't
believe this was gonna happen now you're
here and that person's had enough from
everyone in their lives being bullies
and they're just gonna slump you man and
it's just now you have to come back to
school like a way so like I feel like
bullying is such a weird a weird cycle
because I feel like bullies only bully
because they can't take out the actual
for the actual frustration with their
personal issues yeah on to some
something else said he'd do it onto
someone after that make sense
so boolean that I felt like the reason
why people bully especially in like
school and stuff is because they've got
personal problems at home yeah and
because they can't address it with their
parents
yeah or wherever you just come to school
here but it's like you are like you know
being like said picking bad you by the
bee's knees or whatever which is which
is a mad mad circle happen at uni there
was Batman when we were you need a spare
man that came out from London he said
get sent to the shops in London but in
Coventry began bad mmm big gangster done
some Corleone some yeah but like when I
asked man in London yeah they took your
bike they took your bike and you said
nothing
yeah well in cv1
far Gosford your gas yeah you have your
brand your surface really move are that
totally you have to rebind yourself
especially if you want to if you want to
feel like I said like the outfit you
know the bait oh yeah no one does so you
have to rebrand yourself and you have to
kind of push for the top and push for
whatever whatever happens happens kind
of thing as long as you get there mmm so
we're back James had to step out so just
myself and Jay
how are you been single for a while yeah
so I've been single since about 2017 I
mean almost to 2020 now yeah in in in
that time how is your view of
relationships changed Oh [ __ ]
drastically bro drastic because I was
saying this I felt like I was saying
this to Bella or saying this to someone
recently and that once you once you
actually start a ting with someone well
whoever it may be let's say I'm seeing a
girl I've met this girl I like it we
take Megara I'm one or two dates who
drink we have a good time I see him
multiple times we have sex or whatever
as long as I've asked myself that
question do I see her being my potential
person or do I see her as a better mate
than my previous X if the answer is no
in my head understand as regardless of
whether I end it then or end it in a
month's time yeah I know for a fact the
way I feel about her is gonna change
good I mean so I feel like everyone from
my ex up until whenever have been
fillers does that make sense to you no
but you know I mean it's not it's not
necessarily an insult to them yeah it's
just the way I view my personal
happiness my life obviously I didn't
today it's about me yeah and whatever
they feel is about them as well I might
be their kind of t that like their kind
of guide their guests about people I
might like them as well but if I'm not
100% compatible with them and a hundred
percent like not in that mind frame
where I can see myself as you long-term
yeah like this could be a good two
months thing but long story short if I'm
not hundreds and feeling it I will know
it's gonna end and it would just
resonate to me that you've just been a
filler in my life do you know what your
love languages or Bella was talking to
me about that before I don't actually
deep that much and stuff like that but
she talks to me about that all the time
I can't remember what she told me like
love path this and that but I can't
remember so I think that there are five
I think if anyone see listeners were
and just it doesn't the kind of matters
and it also kind of doesn't I so that's
five so there's acts of service which is
also love languages are about what you
give or what you like to receive oh yeah
yeah so yeah I do you know about this
yeah acts of service is kind of like you
just a problem-solver if anything breaks
anything needs if anyone needs your help
your net yeah quickly you don't like you
you feel fulfilled by being able to lend
help to your loved ones gifts like
materials like eggs myself yeah quality
time mm-hmm
speaks for itself physical touch there's
another one and there's one
words of affirmation yeah is gonna say
like vocals yeah words of affirmation
and but I've always struggled with is
like I'm acts of service and quality
time that's what I like to give and it's
also I like to receive quality time I
don't kind of very self-sufficient I
don't really need anything apart from
just peace of mind yeah so and typically
because of social system unfortunately
for women most of them are words of
affirmation because we've subdued
women's emotions for so long that they
feel the need to have today nearly
validate in either type yeah and but
some attendants that we've raised men to
be void of that and just be toxic and
how much of a man a need to be here so
that's always a conflict of interest so
like I've always kind of ended up with
women who needed words of affirmation
yeah and physical touch and it's just
like that's not my yeah and don't know
where to begin with that like if you do
something nice I tell your yeah but like
I just and I think being a musician
people even think they think you're just
gonna shut yeah yeah and naturally me
like it's not that and and learning that
being compatible there's way more
important and then having love like love
love makes everything easier yeah but
really finding your person where you
guys are
like you if you have the same love and
we just makes your life easier but it
does not but then nervously there's
still other stuff like communication and
Trust in this more so relationships are
dead thing but the thing is so I don't I
agree and disagree without statements
I do disagree purely because they are
stressful but their tasks
everything in life is tossed things
probably too much like it's dope
but it's just I don't think like say
well I'm 28 28 as well so let's say you
meet someone tomorrow mmm they've lived
say for argument's sake they also 28
yeah
28 years without your consent yeah
whether you've got up on a different set
of advice yeah yeah different set of
traumas and then some are you both meant
to understand each other 28 years of a
person loved and being unloved and
loving again and learning how to
communicate a certain way with one
person and work and friendship like you
don't hunt you don't know what
experiences that person has had yeah and
you bought me and like I like you I like
you too mmm I go but the odds are so
stacked against you that's a whole
[ __ ] human being it's an entire
person who thinks a certain way who
responds a certain way who problem
solves a certain way and we have to find
common ground somewhere but us that's
that's the reason why I said to you that
I think that's what boils down to the
fact that everyone in between in my life
of interactors it's been a filler Lord
you know I mean up until you find that
person because no one in life wants to
settle and in fact everyone wants to
feel like they've reached the highest
point they've reached that goal anyone
they've reached that marker you know so
that's the reason why I feel like
everyone else and it's not it's not an
offensive thing no it's not me being
offensive
that's just your true phrase just my
drinking I mean like and a lot of people
might or females especially might think
ice a bit rude but there's no other way
for me to put it without sounding rude
so I feel like the filler is the best
way to describe this in a situation so
for you to say like oh yeah got 28 years
you've lived the part over and then go
but
if you have that common ground you're
more than happy to yeah do you know I
mean but it's just it's also it's just
very slim of course it like I think was
Aziz Ansari I was once saying like like
if you ask everyone's parents where they
met most people it's just similar
neighborhood or on a street or in the
same city or wherever so a lot of people
right up to about 60 years ago day at
people I think that the stats were done
was like I think 90% of relationships
started with her like a 5-mile radius
yeah so the chances are you did grow up
on the same set of advice there was no
internet you didn't get no any insight
into anybody else's life yeah
so if you're like you if you guys yell
at each other
mmm you guys don't take it as offense
because just how you see ya ants
communicate yeah well for me for example
I was born in Nigeria throughout my
whole family my mom and dad's been
married for I think 29 years I've been
together for like 35 mom and dad have
four kids we've never seen my mom and
dad argue yeah we've never seen anyone
raised voice yeah so I live in a West
now where you know people are not more
vocal about how they feel that people
have more of an emotion emotional
response to stuff where people sometimes
yell at each other if I'm in a
relationship and a girl yells at me
what rattles me yeah like I can't fathom
how you got into that way yeah yeah
how are you talking to my - yeah like it
just i salt out yeah I have to leave the
room because I I can't I can't get to
that level with anyone I truly care
about
yeah well I'm yelling over you to get my
point across yeah I finally never get
arrested yeah and and just just me but
for her it's like oh so miss out we
communicate and yeah we'll just I'll
make you breakfast tomorrow and - bless
for me as you can chat to me for days
yeah you call yell at me yeah yeah yeah
yeah we're smart yeah and don't be like
I love you you don't yeah it doesn't
work you don't love me yeah I don't kick
a little bit you can say what you want I
know I love you I was just so much
no I'm no God
like I can't like I can't process and us
yes happening as well as yeah is one
meeting people like you meet ago in
Manchester but she came here from Cayman
Islands yeah so she's grown up on a
holiday for instance yes of vibes and
you've come from an engineering
background or or people are like cross
pollinate in season four your housemate
bettors brazilian yeah and I never used
to happen years ago so yours it's just
so many things having to work
yeah like then if this boils down to
what we were me and Jimmy spoke about
like previous episodes about tradition
and Western civilization obviously back
then it was like like I said it was not
Internet
yeah there was no there was no social
media was nothing that there was none of
that scene that rule it's the face
interact so it made sense that that's
that makes sense that everyone I was
relationships 60 years ago well within
defying my radius well they're in the
same community yeah whereas now because
we've got that insight of Instagram
Twitter all of that stuff we have the
opportunity to expand our horizon yeah
but our parents generation wouldn't
understand the way we are branching up
because all they know is their
upbringing dinair Eastern civilizations
knowledge should I mean yeah so it's
hard it's also harder to especially
convince obviously you know to work
because your nitrogen during as well
it's also harder to convince a Nigerian
parent that you're trying to branch out
in terms of whether it be relationships
whether it be living with a female
whether it will be anything that is not
culturally normal to them
yeah do you not mean no ask tough but
you go that was saying idea like I
caught that damn type of stuff is I used
to bother me so much especially as a
musician yeah trying to seek approval
from family and one day are just kind of
like it's never gonna come mmm like not
because they don't love me but it's just
just grown up on a different wavelength
like different wavelength they will
never be able to come around yeah not
because they don't care it's just they
didn't get their car it doesn't compute
for them yeah like you know my parents
grew up in a space where education
literally was guarantees success yeah
like you got your degree mmm you might
you get a job job yeah we know bear man
who has a degree and doing completely
different from where all I people are
finding ways I think right our
generation has created so many jobs so
many opportunities everyone
self-employed people are doing what
we're doing now yeah and explaining that
to my family just wouldn't make sense
and I just I believe the best way to
sell someone under my idea it's a proof
didn't let it work so I just I just
stopped trying to sell him on it I just
went off and did what I had to do yeah
and all right you don't see you see when
you see and we'll communicate and when
you do understand my you understand
success you understand life drives a
nice car
you know I was gonna ask you this
question especially on this podcast how
did it how did you have to explain to
your family that you'll no longer chase
in education that you're gonna chase
music how did that cuz obviously I know
personally from a Nigerian background
it's hard for a parent to hear that they
they wouldn't want to be in education
anymore they want to chase a lucrative
dream because that's the way parents
would see it especially half comparison
that's the way they would see it yeah
but how did I resonate with you and how
did you like overcome that barrier in
out of your hair as I see I don't think
I ever did or now to be for moms she
probably hasn't said anything for like a
year
yeah but even everything I remember when
I even when I bought my mum's I bought
my mum out of a mortgage yeah
she's still like what are you going to
do mas yeah it's still like there's
still that he's still like like and then
I can I bought a second home and and I
retired my dad as well you know at my
mom and I think after that it stopped
but
I don't I don't know if it's truly
stopped yet like yeah if [ __ ] was to hit
the fan tomorrow the old pitch it right
ycs yeah when its time on you had yeah
yeah and she'd go back and do your
masters and yeah do you a degree but I
think for me it's just never been on my
personality to ask for permission okay
that's a whole also consent consent
permission I just like I just I I think
you know you know when Kalle past you
know as a friend of us from when we were
at uni I think that was really what set
me off yeah I remember coming here I've
called him was an exceptional human
being when he passed it was kind of like
my my logic was if con I could pass a 21
being exceptional human being it was
yeah me being a very mediocre man I have
no chance yeah
so while I'm here I just can't stop I
can't stop asking for permission yeah I
have to go do your thing I have to just
go see what the world has to offer for
me this is the one thing I've done I
genuinely feel joy and like I'm I was
obsessed with music to growing up yeah
and I just stopped asking I think that's
the only I just didn't ask my parents to
say whatever they wanted to say yeah and
told a couple lives here in there you
know like it's probably the worst place
to say this but like I remember when I I
told my family that I was doing a year's
placement in London when I moved to
London I really see London
I took mouse in a year's placement I was
working at a company called Mears yeah
light was someone's couch yeah doing
gigs with my good saw yeah and I gave
myself a time frame I was like come was
that between I said like are that the
placements Dunnan like the 30th of July
yeah and I said to myself if I don't
make a name for myself in that time I'll
call it a day yeah and I think I start
my first work
do I like a 25th of July oh wow and but
the reality is this sounds like a great
story the reality is if it didn't happen
I probably would have kept going yeah
like it was nice to give myself that
goal that goal to work towards but I was
gonna push through regardless I it's
just I think the parcel of Kanye was
always I was always what drove me was
just like I'm you might as well try it
man yeah might as well yeah I hear that
man that's that is tough because it's
crazy that it's won something so moving
in your life made you want to chase
something even more do you know I mean
yeah like it wasn't something that you
decided to do once to be like you know a
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna do it but you
don't want to do it is something that
moved you so much that made you wanna
but the reason I didn't do is
representation which is a whole massive
issue that we talk about what the boys
are not as like the type of music I
wanted to make mm I didn't see anybody
that looks like me make that type of
music so it always felt impossible yeah
so like everything that you are a life
is because you've seen someone that you
relate to do that exact same thing and
in the back of your mind you understand
okay bump being that version of you is
an option
yeah but if you don't see anything in a
representation you feel like you're
going out on a limb because it's like
there's no safety blanket you don't know
yeah that this is possible I think so
but and I remember Kona used to tell me
all the time why you should do it you
should do it you should do it I was just
kind of right no no no no no that's not
a big my money yeah I don't sing when I
was singing out yeah but I didn't and
then after I remembered I think the
first proper show I had was at his
funeral
oh really yeah Wow it's waiting call it
a show but like his family was like ah
he would love you to do it mmm and the
first time I really got up on a stage
stage it wasn't just like gimmicky mmm
you know me and my guitar was a his
funeral and just never I just never
stopped I think one day I I just left
carve moved to London
I didn't I didn't go back to Birmingham
yeah and I've stayed in London for seven
years
honestly what I think back I don't know
who I thought I was yeah I find it so
bizarre that I had balls that big
because I probably don't even have that
anymore yeah I think the older you get
you kind of naturally become safe up
yeah you said come to life you know like
I'm look after all my siblings and my
mum and dad so it's like I never want to
jeopardize that that safety blanket that
I've created but back then I was it was
wayward and I like I I passed the
apartment my first apartment when I
lived in London it was like on top of
this little I remember 24 hours like I
was at yeah yeah I remember I remember
you know I was thinking raw like I often
play this game in my mind way if I go
past something I'm very nostalgic person
in general if I see something from my
past I tried to remember what my mindset
was like did I ever envision this
version of myself yeah she I'm saying
like yeah even at uni yeah it's an icy
everyman like who we are today was never
even an option and it's weird to think
that because your current version of
yourself is so your version today is the
smartest version of yourself
yeah and that version if he knows [ __ ]
hmm but it is the most knowledgeable the
most version of you that's connected and
most information yeah but that version
of you knows nothing yeah and that's
scary like five years from now I wonder
what we're going to think when we look
back at all of this yeah I hope we're
going to be proud and whatever but the
reality is man no no nothing I would
just aren't here yeah that's true just
aren't here no common sense and we just
know we know what we're told and we try
to make a better life but we don't know
[ __ ] and I find that thought really
daunting and scaring away because you
know you're thinking about like what the
rest of your life looks like mmm you're
gonna meet your kid for the first time
and all that kind of stuff yeah I was
gonna be old boss nearly 13 Oh looks
dead
yeah bro I was at thousand I was in
Canada yeah I know it's this old breath
oh oh he was trying to get there from a
pavement Oh
trembling Jesus like shaking he can old
and I saw I ran over and I helped him
down looked into his car I he literally
had to walk about five steps yeah and he
was petrified of like he couldn't reach
he's trying to put his hand in a car
yeah to get down from a pavement house
man driving now he's his missus drove
his mrs. Porter cos I found a [ __ ] oh I
had the door open and everything not
just yeah mine was shaken Jesus is so
boring
yeah are you can't walk to look hot yeah
go I live life to the fullest clean oh
yeah Bauer's read something he says
you're gonna live about 60% of your life
of a bad back
yeah that's dead that is wild he's wack
most of your life your back will hurt
[ __ ] dad did yeah that is that I'm so
upset about
right now I have bad knees as well my
knees already like you start hearing it
when you get older you start hearing
that you're making these grunts for no
reason yeah I pick up the remote control
I have to grunt mmm like I'm just I hate
it's just like nah man
Jacob used to be agile thanks for the I
own these streets no mine use the brake
dad yeah I used to be a dancer now if
you try to be dancers now right what I'm
on stage now like when I watch people
sometimes I feel like I could do that I
try I do like a little hop and a skip
back and forth tired yeah time if I went
on stage I'm like I always give a
grandiose performance but I'm not
running I'm not running I'm not dancing
mm-hm become tired comes right
hey I hate saying that happy man and
mother time is killing me
randoms random question father type
random question about like your music
career and stuff where is I wouldn't I
would I don't to say where's the best
place you've ever performed because I'm
sure there's so many that come to mind
but what's one of the most memorable
places you performed up I say the most
memorable one I perform at as Moscow why
because it's [ __ ] Moscow you never
just leave just I just never it was
never in the cards for me
yeah and given to racial tension hmm and
I was just caught off guard
yeah sure so that hello quick and they
knew every single word there is which
always kind of happens but it's just I
never thought yeah the source will get
here mmm
and seeing these people saying how much
they cared and and just thinking from my
point of view it's like there were times
why I almost didn't want to do this
yeah and I'm here like my craft just
taking me here but I would never go to
Moscow never gonna win on and yeah I
know today back yeah I have seen seeing
it that the things I get to experience
purely because of my hobby mmm always
always blows my mind that I can't
believe I get to do this for a living I
can't believe I I'm so lucky that I get
to see these places and meet these
people yeah and and come all the way to
Moscow was was special
I just never never thought that would be
an option for me that's [ __ ] Moscow yeah
I saw the blinds I think it was like a
hundred capper when we come back were
playing and I can pick a room bomb but
still must get but it's just my birthday
and it was just it's just insane yeah
and so much love so much love I also
understand that the love I get is
privileged it's not what the average
experience to be for a black man or
might be I don't know but I am NOT like
don't be in a haste of go you know be a
tourist in Moscow do your research but
for me I was I'm invited I'm living
privileged life yeah in this black guys
it's a long time since I've been in a
room that I've been invited to so I
never really have to my gods always done
yes I'm like I'm around I for you to
meet me at this point in my life is
you'd have had to go through my manager
my tour manager my my managers
day-to-day guy
yeah so but it's how you meet me you've
got through people that I love and
respect so much that you have to be a
decent human being I God is always down
yeah so I can't vouch for my experience
has been the average experience fair
enough yeah that makes total sense yeah
that's a lot of fun but I wanted this a
couple more places I would indeed Brazil
mmm been back to Nigel I've never I've
always postpone - oh I haven't haven't
had a homecoming show and I haven't
taught anywhere in Africa why is that
um it's just uncharted grounds and it's
just like because of your niche of music
no no no like that it's definitely there
I could definitely I've had many offers
to do it okay but it's just I don't want
to deal one-off so I want to do a tour
yeah yeah I can come to a show in Lagos
or whatever but it's just as there's
also the logistical side flying in seven
people to play a show for an hour
doesn't always make sense yeah I want to
do a whole tour I want to go from now
and you Lagos I want to do your Accra I
want to do South Africa
yeah Johannesburg and Cape Town and
maybe Kenya but it's just logistics of
these shows I haven't been around it
before okay so it's like it's just
there's a lot of master there's a
business side to music that I'd not find
out but I have to do every now and again
and it's just not always possible
like when I tour I do a route that's
been done before
yeah I've seen someone do it before
something like it just exhibited a bus
parks at this motel driver sleeps for 10
hours and so you know like but no one's
ever done it so it's not no one I know
antara by the way I want to do it yeah
typically people fly by yeah I would
definitely that's that that's probably
lost time I leave everything else I've
had the privilege of doing
there's a couple more places but are
there places that you've not been to
that you'd want to go to mmm
obviously you said the places in Africa
anywhere that way right because it's
brought like out there's no place I
wouldn't go yeah if anyone says yeah
boom there's people here I work more
common yeah if it's feasible and
possible yeah yeah
there's no way I wouldn't I wouldn't
want to go apart for the places I've
mentioned and when I've been to places
I've been to play I know yeah I've been
to I was in the place called Moncton in
Canada yes weeks ago I was random I
liked Halifax in Canada like I've been
to places like deep Switzerland I love I
love kinda Switzerland it's fun there's
nowhere that comes to mind apart from
South South America already like Mexico
mmm Mexico Argentina would be nice yeah
because I love to travel as well I love
ya I love culture I love seeing people I
love learning about people people are by
far the most magical things like like
even when I travel like I know we drove
up here before I was just seeing if the
fact that I can go somewhere and see
people yeah it's like you're just out
here just also live in your life yeah
feeding your kids living your dreams
I find it much that this is the reality
a lie you fly eight hours in you land
there's people that like I really like
they just aren't here you might have
just really just live in you're lying
here like you're just here yeah and you
got somewhere else this is their tune
like humans just everywhere just live in
their life and getting to experience
that it's just always mind-blowing to me
and I never can understand why you care
mmm at least most of these songs I I
made in my bedroom or like a dangerous
studio and wolf London somewhere
and it's like I can't believe you give a
[ __ ] hmm why would you I don't I give a
some level but yeah I believe you care
yeah that much yeah I want to listen to
me alive yeah and listen to it is best
fired party to leave your yard yeah
you're saying I forgive you so much yeah
my evening you've worked a nine-to-five
in yeah you're tired but you say you
know what Jacobs here and that's such a
gift like yeah hi I'm like I say at that
time is Cora de'cine my name is whatever
you know you make your money back
yeah yeah but when you spend time time
is the actual currency because you won't
see this again yeah you'll never get
back and I mean you gift someone your
time that's the most humble didn't think
someone could ever do for me and every
time I'm just gobsmacked and I can't
believe you man I hear that's calm her
that's very cool
you know it's fun it's fun you guys are
gonna do that singing start touring ah
you know what the show on the road
I would I would love to because at the
end of the day like obviously we both
know this is this was all Jimmy's idea
no I didn't he just threw me a back one
who like do you want to do it me Jose
yeah [ __ ] it were just we talk like this
anyway so but it blew my mind when
you're talking about the guys you know
as well from spot at Farnborough blah
and it's just like I can't believe
people actually subscribe to that you
know I mean obviously I know people do
but like it blows my mind like the
finance is behind that as well and how
people actually talk and do a pod you
I'm sitting there what should you man
talk yeah like people do tours for that
that blows my mind because human beings
are interested yeah like but what I
found the most is that nobody wants to
feel alone like you when you're driving
you put music artists it's company yeah
it's like and you were listening to
people speak you feel like you can
relate to them there's something magical
about that like like are these man gay
yeah like that yeah yeah I guess yeah
like yeah like I'm not like people will
pay anything for that to not feel like
I'm the only person that feels the same
way like because everyone feels like a
freak even like sexually you like oh boy
then you hear that I should I'm into
that too I'm so sick yeah like everybody
wants to feel seen man ultimately and
that's why I Pike advocate as see your
people like see the people in your life
make sure if you're seen and heard
because ultimately everybody just wants
to feel like oh man you notice me yeah
and I feel like I belong somewhere yeah
I got back to initial point of like even
my people people why people do negative
things it's like at least you see me mmm
have you seen the Joker yeah the same
thing like for him it was just like me
now yeah before you mine in case I would
make in here I walking steps bedtime oh
let's run let's do this I'm gonna dance
on these stairs now like and it's what
it is Boris it's a good way good contact
points that's actually crazy yeah it
does just boreback full second to the
pudding conversation beginning this is
actually crazy lady speaking as a
comedian she was even saying that she's
like the reason she's a comedian it was
because she just like she wanted her
parents to notice her yeah like it was
kind of like as Whitney Cummings
she was saying like are like you know
like even that it's like most of the
things that we become it's still are
seeking approval yeah from loved ones
just TBC might not if I may if I get
that scar maybe maybe that will happen
yeah yeah this may be fought just like
this maybe from one but maybe yeah like
it's polished but dreaming but so much
of that about see your people man and
not even let them know they're seen and
loved and show up for them because yeah
man everyone s pair of us I was about
seven billion or something on it yeah
I've also the people feel alone
true-true there's bear of us that's
literally can't people can't stop
[ __ ] yeah and people Steve people
still feel like the only one on the
planet and that's mad to me that's why
that's why I do what I do man I wish I
make music to keep people company that's
my job and get the Squealer we out is
anything else you want to add before you
wrap up
anything you want to say to the people I
live your best life man be nice always
be be nice and and learn learn about
people learn about your struggles learn
about the oppressions and you know yes
just be decent human being if you can
and unsecured a bag nice one nice one
obviously James hat sir that's a part
ways earlier on [ __ ]
I've been myself you heard obviously
we've got Jacob banks in today or the
will the info will be in the
descriptions below and you know go
follow ah thank you bro appreciate it
appreciate you can follow his journey
you can follow our journey so yeah mom
it's good to have you bro yes sir yeah
man do it again soon please